[Musique]
mademoiselle chase
quelle est la toute première chose que
vous vous rappelez quand vous étiez dans
la simulation personnes se souvient de
rien pourquoi on s'est retrouvé là alors
c'est quoi notre bateau a fait naufrage
on est sur une île on sait pas comment
on a atterri là elle va bien falloir
qu'on survivre il faut qu'on tienne prêt
ou alors on se tenir d'ici
ça promet d'être beaucoup plus intense
encore si vous agissez mal il vous rend
la monnaie de votre pièce
elle m'inspire pas confiance
volà
si tu as une hallucination
je commence enfin à comprendre ce qui se
passe
si là-bas vous y rester
ici aussi remanié
[Musique]
sheikh schwab très déterminé la suite
vous croyez qu'ils pourront s'en sortir
le maître mort je ne crois pas à nos
fins
[Musique]
toute ma vie à me retenir
a eu ni sage demandé
[Musique]
on doit trouver ce minerai l'ambré
royère quelqu'un approche alors ça est
une petite fille
on est dans le même bateau tous les deux
je t'aiderai à quitter cette planète si
tu m'aides a trouvé le minerai pourquoi
c'était fréquent fiancée
parce que je peux te protéger
belambra royal où es tu y es tu vas
devoir me faire confiance
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle harry et puis de
toute façon c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on tombe sur ce type de bahts surtout
au marché noir où est mon vote
où est passé mon pote je sais pas
dumas dit que c'était une crise
cardiaque tu m'expliques pour la colonne
pourquoi les briser
ce qui compte pour moi c'est les enfants
mais les bas ce sera mieux pour est sans
leur père parce que les bottes vont
finir par remplacer l'homme dans tous
les domaines de notre vie ce lien c'est
un pote c'est qu'un bout de métal
vous êtes maintenant identifiée comme
utilisateur principal la famille est
complet
j'ai vu vous travaillez avec des robots
doha vous ai personnellement je les aime
pas beaucoup
on peut jamais savoir s'ils disent
vraiment la vérité qu'est-ce que tu
serais prête à faire pour ta famille
n'importe quoi
nos adversaires sont redoutables
[Applaudissements]
ça va être difficile de gagner mais
quand tu as le sentiment que c'est perdu
d'avancé et que tant de temps fuir
rappelle toi comment tu en est arrivé là
[Musique]
ils ont prises angers pas perdu mais je
n'ai pas perdu ma technique
on va bientôt se battre contre fantômes
il arrive de los angeles
on accueille au tom cruise
[Applaudissements]
seul véritable obstacle il est juste là
c'est seulement pendant que vous dansez
vous avez l'impression des monts le
maître du monde
[Applaudissements]
sky cruz ne disparaîtra pas
[Musique]
vous vous citez un aspect
peu importe qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde
j'aurai réussi à marquer les esprits
[Musique]
et si on te demande comment tu es venu
en métro en passant par quelle station
salazar et ensuite porte de champerret
je vais tout déchirer j'espère bien par
pas tout quand même un baiser centres
d'accueil
le diagnostic c'est quoi ce fanatisme
particulièrement sévère j'ai eu
l'assistante sociale et les mineurs et
demandant le placement judiciaire
il est même dangereux environ quinze
jours je trouve une solution
j'imagine avec de dire à tout le monde
j'ai trouvé de solution c'est qu'ils
aient trop collant à ses inspecteurs
les gars se sait ce que c'est
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales c'est dans le viseur vous avez
pris des initiatives qui pose des
questions nous avons à charge de revenir
à une situation qui donne plus de
sécurité
cette association répond aux besoins
chance à l'accepter patients que la
société refuse ou qui semblent
impossibles à améliorer
m
pour moi je vais vous dire il ya ceux
qui vous regardent plutôt ce qui vous
est peu plus pierre les autres
mais croyez moi que son plan pour eux
depuis 15 ans les médecins les hôpitaux
m'appelle tous les jours sur mon
portable pour savoir si on peut
accueillir encore d'autres enfants
pis tu dépense trop d'argent c'est bien
trop bon
vous c'est à vous qu'on se raccrocher
la plupart des internautes peu diplômés
vous connaissez beaucoup diplôme qui
prépare à ce congé de droite toute la
journée
tu le connais c'est la fermeture
ce que je peux la tête contre ton épaule
[Musique]
et l'actrice vous a le plus fortement
transmis son adn
enfin je vois vraiment personne vous
avez la visite j'ai peut-être vous vous
laissiez alors n'ont aucune importance
c'est ma fille avec sa petite famille et
les pousser jeu cet acte hommes aux
acteurs ces dernières en mots il vienne
pour le féliciter pour son livre quand
il parlait de tirer à 120 exemplaires me
rende pas une crapule
je fais du vanni tueuse c'est quoi sa
maman attendre ma fille devant le
portail de son école mes tétons joie
qu'elle sait jamais arrivé une seule
fois qu'elle en r2
comment ça se passe sur le tournage
palabrant pas son texte
non mais c'est pas trop tard tu as tout
passait pas en 40 ans comment ça tu t'en
vas aussi un peu soudain n'ont donc que
tu fais ça sans toi elle va pas s'en
sortir
[Musique]
mouah ah non vous formez un bon deal ou
alors c'est hors de question
maintenant ça va commencer la évite de
maths les mamans doigt comment veux tu
t'appelles autrefois j'étais pas comme
ça mais j'ai toujours connu comme ça
tu vas prendre un peu plus de soin
d'aujourd'hui tous préfèrent avoir été
une mauvaise mère nouveaux amis que vous
une bonne actrice et onenote terreur
qu'est ce que je vais faire pour luc
commence par tex que j'ai jamais excusé
auprès d'un homme tu t'excuses à tous
trompés mais tu t'es jamais excusé pour
[Musique]
jamais venus voir la pièce que j'ai joué
dessus
le magicien douce celui de rennes on est
bien d'accord tu jouais pas dorothée
l'épouvantail
bein ma fille il ya des choses que tu ne
peux pas comprendre et auquel tu est
destiné tu seras femme la plus
formidable que ce royaume à la noix et
jamais
c'est pas vrai quelle heure il est 3h du
mat au il vous est déjà arrivé de faire
un arrêt à la dernière seconde tout à
coup vous vous réveillez et en fait tout
va bien et bat aujourd'hui c'est pas ça
le royaume entier a été changé en pierre
ma mère est démoniaque et elles font est
mort c'était le pauvre elle fore coupe
tu puisses être je suis désolé
je suis au septième ciel pourquoi il
gâché un temps fou à rester en vie
un écran chat en attente pour monsieur
helfaut à l'eau allons l faut c'est bien
toi un homme c'est vous qui m'avez
appelé je n'ai pas accès aux paradigmes
et s'il faut nous retrouvent en enfer je
sais comment sortir inhabituels ou swim
rabel damon
[Musique]
qui êtes vous juanita il mon truc en
plus sa valeur assez réaliste il y à une
prophétie qu'il faut accomplir
telle mère telle fille je suis pas comme
toi je sais je vous à moi que vous
vouliez voir quelque chose de très cool
voyant cachant nous tous cette pile de
mouflets
il faut sauver l faut il rendre à
dreamland sa gloire quoi qu'il puisse
arriver
eh bien je me battrai
va falloir gérer ça d'une façon
dangereusement banca c'est ce que
j'appelle la méthode dreamland
ah oui
fitch suit son dragon que le meilleur
d'entre eux n'est le confort ou la
meilleure essayons de ne pas oublier les
femmes
quelle est la principale menace à
l'échelle mondiale
le venezuela possède les plus grandes
réserves de pétrole de la planète
alors pourquoi ce pays traverse l'une
des pires crises humanitaires de
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc vous pensez que les rues se vendent
leur destine mans des armes au venezuela
ce serait logique d'après son nom par
save a causé la panique en cas d'attaqué
nucléaire du venezuela vous ne lirez pas
dans la presse parce qu'on sera tous
morts
[Musique]
loisirs ont affaire jack affaire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé reyes
regardez moi son nom est il était
mentionné si vous restez vous ne serez
pas protéger personne viendra vous
sauver
si on le fait on le fait ensemble c'est
pas un problème
une fois il est resté pendant plus de 16
heures face ce type avant qu'ils se
mettent à paray l'ancien chef elle
adorait il était déjà ma tentative de
manipulation sont pathétiques situés
tous au ventre on craque pour y passer
la nuit
je vais tenter autre chose c'est
n'importe quoi je te demande pas de
m'apprécier je te demandent d'obéir
parce que les diplômes de cloud j je
vous faire muter en moins de temps que
vous n'imaginez tu es fait on en faire
là c'est la procédure
j'essaie de faire ce job en restant
derrière ton miroir
ça marche pas comme ça y a que vous qui
puissiez nous aider tout ce qu'on veut
c'est la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]